it's a new week and it's the start of
August and this week we get to go back
back to the past with rare replay a
compilation of 30 games including the
xbox 360 ports of banjo kazooie banjo
tooie and perfect dark just to be clear
it's not the nintendo 64 versions
several rare titles are not included in
the compilation due to licensing issues
so you're not going to get donkey kong
country or goldeneye double-oh-seven but
you do still get some of those major
classics and it comes with a bonus
documentary feature that you unlock as
you play your favorite get in that sweet
nostalgia on the fourth also this week
we get the two-dimensional sci-fi
shooter from space with galaxies the
dimensional now on ps4 the game's levels
are procedurally generated for each
playthrough and they are connected as an
endless space dungeon the levels include
spawners for enemies and traps to keep
it interesting sadly the Vita version
got lost in space but ps4 is here with
PC on the way stay alive on the poor wii
u gets a kick ass game this week with
freedom planet you get the speed and
movement from classic sonic games and
then you get to throw in some combat and
boss fights from Mega Man and seal the
deal with fun retro music and mini
missions definitely worth a look if
you've never seen it before and if you
don't have a wii u it's also out on pc
so no excuses fight for freedom on the
third there's been a lot of time
consuming dungeon crawlers lately with
all those etrian odyssey is coming out
but etrian oddysey to untold is the
seventh entry in the Etrian franchise
and has a level of refinement that could
only come from consumer feedback improve
systems and mapping make this one of the
most approachable Etrian titles to date
reviewer Heidi Kemp said it's great to
have a modern re-imagined version of the
original etrian oddysey to but don't
expect etrian oddysey untold two to
deliver a revolutionary experience if
you've crawled through this dungeon
before fans of the series can pick this
up on the fourth finally we get a
beautiful water covered world with
submerged with a heavy wind waker vibe
you explore a large expansive area
looking for supplies needed to help your
injured brother finally the Waterworld
game we needed now all we need is Kevin
Costner
calm and serene this game docks in to
ps4 on the 4th and xbox one on the 7th
for further details visit gamespot com
release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week
you